あのよく言われるんですけども
うるさいとか
近所の人大丈夫ですか？
とか言われるんですけども
この部屋は安全です
ご安心ください
と言いつつもですよ
実は
僕がどれくらい、うるさいかっていうのは
僕自身あんまり分かってないんですよ
で今まで結構いろんなでかい音をするものを
使ってきたんですけども
それが
実際どれくらいの音かっていうは
僕自身
あんまり
わかってないないんすよ
正直ね
だから今日は、僕は、一体、どれくらいうるさいのかってのを
ちょっと自分で感じてみようと思いまして
こちらを準備しました
もう、開けちゃったんだけどね
これはね欲しかった
あっ、くっそやろうォ
開けずらいやつだ
これでさ、こう、元からこうゆうのやめてほしいよね
きたきたきたきた
こちらです
ディンシャンシャンブラブメンタ
これは何をするものかといいますと
見てもらうとわかるとおり
音の大きさを測るものです
今日はこれを
グサッ（手に刺さる音）
今日はこれを使って
僕自身が一体どれくらいうるさいのか
いろんなもののうるささを
ちょっとこれで図れればいいなと思っております
これで音がわかるわけよ
どれくらいうるさいかっていうのが
あああ！
もう今のも音でかいですからね
普段叫ぶ声がどれくらいの大きさなのかわかんないからさぁ
やってみるっきゃないんっすよ
できたぞよぉ　つきましたよ！